shadow crew
we had this guy
albert gonzalez this kid's name
we had we were growing so big that
i had to start farming things out so the
first thing i started farming i i
instituted this review system
kind of establishing that trust
mechanism even further for criminals to
use
we needed somebody to take care of our
tech aspects of the forum so um
associate of mine by the name of kim
taylor
we were looking for a forum techie he
comes to me one night and he's like a
founder forum techie i was like who's
that he's like
this kid and i was like is any good he's
like well he knows the software and i
was like okay
we just signed his ass on he went by the
screen name of cumbajani was his screen
name and
he starts selling credit cards after a
while under his screen name of scarface
and
that cbv1 breach where you're cashing
out the track twos at atms
you know forty thousand dollars a day
so albertson new jersey one day
broad daylight
and
stands at an atm
for 40 minutes
just standing there
feeding in one atm card after another
point out cash taking the 20s out stuff
them in that backpack
meanwhile just across the street a
couple of cops just happened to be there
and they start noticing
this kid's just standing there
so 40 minutes they watch this kid 40
minutes
finally one cop looks at the other
let me see what's going on there
walks over across the street albert's
wearing a wig he's got the disguise on
everything else like that ask him kid
what are you doing albert falls apart
we didn't know albert had been arrested
so albert immediately goes in
i want to work for the secret service
at that point in time secret service
i referred to and i i want to make sure
that i don't say that it's it's not like
that anymore but back then they were
[ __ ] idiots
all right they had no clue what was
going on so there was a confidence issue
that they were working through it's one
way to put it that's a nice that's a
nice euphemism
[ __ ] idiots there's another way to
say it so they're just like not aware of
the digital world they have no clue no
clue the way that uh albert tells them
how to catch us because they looked at
them how do we catch them and alfred's
like
i'm serious i'm serious so albert's like
well you could try a vpn
what's a vpn yeah so he explains it to
him they're like
that's a good idea
so i quit shadow crew i was worried
about all the news that was coming in
everything like that i'm stealing 160k a
week i didn't know albert had been
arrested
i'm worried about being arrested i know
the writing's on the wall and i'm like
i'm quitting
where did you see the writing like the
ieps that were coming in yeah the uh
text messages about the secret service
investigation building and the buildings
buildings and this is not going to end
well yeah this is this is this is going
to be bad so
i announced my retirement of february
15th
i'm sorry april 15th
2004
that's my retirement i think that's
2004.
and uh i quit i walk away well albert
had been arrested
they cut him loose no one knows he's
been arrested he comes back into shadow
crew
i leave kim taylor at the same time he's
kind of on the run which if you want to
know that story that's a nightmare story
in and of itself
so my second in charge kim taylor this
guy there was this uh guy named david
oh what was his name
he was el mariachi was was the guy's
name david thomas david yeah yeah he was
a film guy so scarface yeah yeah so el
mariachi real name david thomas
he's on the run out of nebraska for
check fraud
he comes to us on shadow crew telling us
this sad story we take up a collection
for this guy
send it to him all right i get him a job
working with a low level carter
trying to make him some money all right
el mariachi or thomas does this for a
few weeks comes to me one day and he's
like man i'm not making any money i'm
like okay let me see what i can do well
i had a ukrainian guy by the name of big
buyer he um
a real friend of mine and i contacted
him i was like look man i got a guy that
wants to do some work can you help the
guy out he's like i got him i was like
okay so he sends thomas enough money to
go thomas is in texas at that point
sends thomas enough money to go from
texas to issaquah washington and rent an
office space all right
so thomas goes up there rents his office
space him and his girlfriend rents an
office space
and the plan is this big buyer is going
to
place an order
get product sent
mariachi is going to get the product
listed on ebay cash out 50 50. easy
enough all right
so big buyer places an order first order
is outpost.com 18 000.
the largest order outpost.com had ever
received at that point in time order
goes through because the stuff goes
through he gets the product all right
mariachi comes back tells me tells my
second in charge kim taylor kim taylor
at this point he's i'm i'm 33 34.
kim taylor taylor's 46 he works at the
tattered covered bookstore in denver
colorado that's where he works at this
point and he fancies himself jason
bourne
all right he's even got one of the
screen names of jason bourne
so i'm like all right so
mariachi's telling us how much how much
money he's making everything else i'm
like well that's good i'm glad you're
all right
kim contacts me he's like i want to go
to issaquah and i was like why he's like
to make some money i'm like you're
making money he's like i want to go to
issaquah i was like all right go be
careful so he gets in the car
saturn is what he's driving he drives
his little piece a piece of saturn all
the way up to issaquah gets there you
know midnight
they party all night long because
they've never met each other they're
just celebrating partying drinking
everything else like that
meanwhile
big buyer
has placed another order
with outpost dot com
seventeen thousand dollars
the second largest order outpost.com had
ever received at that point in time
by this point in time outpost knows the
first order was fraudulent guess where
it's going the exact same address the
first order goes
so outpost picks up the phone calls
issaquah pd hey we got a fraudster
issaquah is like
would you mind sending some empty boxes
and the outpost is like be happy to
so the rule was
is on credit card fraud if you've got
full account access
you place the order the morning that's
supposed to arrive you sign into the
bank account or the credit card account
if you can sign in you go pick up your
product if you can't sign in you go back
to sleep that day all right
well big buyer was the guy who placed
the order
mariachi in my second in charge are
partying all right so they're supposed
to contact big buyer
they don't meanwhile big buyer is
raising hell getting up with me like hey
where are you where are the guys i can't
find them they don't need to pick up
this product
so i can't get in touch with them
they go down to pick up the so
mariachi's got a cadillac old 70s
cadillac he's got a cadillac
pulls into the complex
now mariachi's driving
kim taylor's in the passenger seat
david thomas's girlfriend's in the back
seat as they pull into the complex going
through the parking lot mariachi just
happens to glance over and he sees a van
with a guy sitting sideways in the van
and he looks at kim taylor and he's like
that's an undercover
and kim's like ah it's fine so they pull
up to the office complex
kim's like i'll go in and get the
packages
so he walks in
looks at the guy behind the counter i
believe you have some packages for us
guys like one second
so he disappears around the wall out
pops the issaquah pd arrest kim
david thomas is in the car watching all
this happen he bugs out and they arrest
him on the interstate
where he has three fake driver's
licenses in his wallet along with his
real driver's license another no-no but
they get him so
david thomas had outstanding warrants
out of nebraska we couldn't bond him out
kim taylor didn't have any warrants so
we bonded him out um
my third in-charge kid
seth sanders was his name
he bonds him out uses his girlfriend's
account to bond him out and uh
i get married i get kim taylor
to go to utah where he
uh another friend of mine agrees to
house him him and his wife
so i think everything's fine and all
that
about three weeks later this guy in utah
gets me on the phone hey
he's got to go
i'm like what's going on
he's like well
the only thing he's doing is popping
ecstasy tablets every day all day and
i'm like seriously he's like yeah i was
like okay he's got to go so we kick him
out of there by this point i've got
another crew that's coming through i
mean i had all these crews running had
another crew that's coming through
denver
send kim back to denver to partner up
with these guys
kim gets these guys arrested so by this
point in time i'm exasperated i just
want to throw my hands up in the air and
walk away
so my retirement's coming up at the same
time so i'm like [ __ ] it i'm done
so i tell everybody the rest of the
admins and the mods there i'm like this
is what's going on you guys need to
watch out for this we need to ban kim
not let him back in
be careful what's going on i walk away
at the same time i walk away
cumber johnny albert gonzalez comes back
into play he sees everything that's
going on he uses that to his advantage
he starts banning everyone that's
suspicious of him
sets up the vpn at the same time and
says hey to make sure we're all secure i
need all transactions to go through this
vpn vpns ran by the secret service
all right secret service ends up i think
they ended up cataloging like seven
million dollars worth of transactions
over the next four or five months
shadow crew makes the front cover of
forbes
august 2004 headline who's stealing your
identity
october 26 2004 united states secret
service arrests 33 people six countries
six hours
i was in charleston south carolina when
i saw it happen and i'm like
you know thank you
you're you're the one that got away i'm
the one public there were a couple other
guys that got away that they didn't
publicly mention one uh his his name was
tron he was a um in the zero yeah
exactly but uh
he went by the screen name tron he had
access almost unfettered access to bank
of america
so what happens is they identified the
guy
secret service is in the air to go get
him they call the ukrainian police hey
we're coming down to rest this guy
ukrainian cops are like oh come on down
so as soon as they get off the phone
ukrainian cops get in the car
go down and tell tron hey they're
they're coming to get you yeah
so he bugs out down to south america and
they don't catch him i think for six or
seven years after that something
caught them eventually caught them
eventually
you